[Music]
in gone too soon news
oh don't [ __ ] say that guys [ __ ]
names submitted by Devine so with an
apostrophe and then she had to put in
parentheses how to pronounce it are we
doing JK news at an Indian Reservation
or what no one's like praying for rain
in the back I think he knows we're
rolling ha
gave me this and he brought it directly
from the Philippines and it's been too
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] ask Pat it's been
blessed by a Filipino shaman well as a
volcano can you stop playing our
people's music that's right you're not
Mexican its appropriation appropriating
my music you're literally the dude at
the corner that people give money to
stop hey practice makes perfect
it's my first day with this tool come
back when you're perfect okay
controversial rapper xxx 10th St on I
don't I know I don't to say no everyone
pronounces attend to see oh no it's X
temptation that's only Mexican people
know the people that I saw it like this
it then the see all know that I I look
that [ __ ] up hardcore I don't know why
do you think is a Spanish word I just
don't want you to get flamed for it
that's why it's expectation David see
over urban authorities whatever David
yeah flame David anyway he was shot dead
at 20 years old okay that's that
and what was it any of the controversial
is he was controversial well I know why
I read I watched a story on this tell me
I didn't watch it so I just got one day
comments all over X extant akan rip the
[ __ ] transformer I'm like yeah I'm
like yeah
xxx rip I'm like why are you putting
that on my comments I don't know
apparently in his past he said a lot of
homophobic things sold goshawk or no not
said a lot of horrible things he said
that he beat up his cellmate in jail
because he thought he was gay
then he smeared the guy's blood on his
face and so that's what that's one thing
and it's all the gate so the gay
gangsters came and shot him I don't know
I actually don't know who shot him
that's his rap lyrics all right I don't
know you ever won those rappers live oh
you said that on a pocket yeah he said
on a podcast and he was kind of like
bragging about it I see and then he also
there were reports of domestic violence
from his ex-girlfriend right
yeah that huge that means that she was
pregnant yeah yeah I'm just like hearing
bits and pieces but apparently he
punched her so much it made one of her
eyes blind for a little bit like she was
ocular surgery yeah are people bringing
this up to say that it's okay he died
like what's the point of it so that's
why it's controversial because some
people are celebrating is that good
riddance yeah yeah and then some people
are like cuz later but right before he
died he's trying he tried to like I
don't know be reborn with his life yeah
and like do a lot of charity work
spreading a positive message of love and
so a lot of people are like forgetting
his past he's a young kid yeah he did
some stupid [ __ ] but like he's trying he
was trying to make a change and trying
to better himself and he was growing as
a person so shame on you for being happy
about his death I never heard about him
but when I first saw his picture I
thought it was like a Rastafarian who
got in a fight with a tattoo machine I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are but
someone [ __ ] you up with the tattoo
machine dude yeah why is he got a black
guy no I thought I thought that too but
it's actually a tattoo who he did it on
purpose
yeah what about his Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup what do you mean it's a
tattoo
it's a gratitude Underwood I like a red
thing oh my god like to make it look
like he has her I don't know if he made
it so what's that how come he died was
it like gang gang violence yeah it was
shot in the neck and it seems like he
died immediately he was that's said he
was shopping for a motorcycle in Florida
when someone just drove just ran upon
him I bet you is one of the gay
gangsters do they know who killed him
that's his body he's picture
I would be offended Falls if I was a
part of a game and I heard that
gangsters gangsters if I heard that guy
kill to kill one of my gay homies cuz
like or one of our people because like
just because of the preference of the
dick I want to see that drive-by the
excuse me
who cut roll the window down sing boom
be tight dude cop me [ __ ] now they
[ __ ] roll up on a scooter and in one
homies of the bag and it'll be like
cocked me and then the guy in the back
boom or they see like this I put your
gun out I [ __ ] got you that second
tight no nothing that you dad know
that's such a stereotype guys yeah but
it's not very funny have you guys seen
gay gangsters no it's a real thing when
I was in junior high
they were like next on FOX 11 they're
gay and they're gangsters thanks are the
california gay gangs are [ __ ] up the
neighborhood propaganda oh like all
those gates although me yes it's it's
real they're sitting in the bathtub so
charged you there's no gay cholos
no there's right there in the bathtub
they're taking prom pictures it's like
one tall bald-headed guy a shorter
bald-headed guy but you wouldn't say
[ __ ] today I know I'm scared yeah
they're called polos dude oh my god
that's kind of adorable
that's [ __ ] scary as [ __ ] like they
found their person they found their
person a who join us
I love you so much foo
I'm scared and mad
I'm with it get you a guy like that
loves you like a gay cholo yeah and it
so follows a part of that crew I'd be
outraged if I heard that someone killed
one of us just because of existing
that's like we already have it hard well
he didn't kill him he just beat him into
submission and smeared his blood on his
face yeah see that's messed up cuz that
that's like oh I beat his ass because he
was Asian and I [ __ ] took his blood
and made egg rolls out of it yeah
exactly sure like that look at the [ __ ]
he looks so tiny and weak though so I
wonder how small that guy was that he'd
beat him up that bad and he's only 20 so
it might have been in juvenile hall
where everyone's smaller mmm unless you
have a Samoan cellmate yeah so you keep
asking if they caught who killed Umbreon
so they still haven't caught them oh I
didn't know who it is two guys on a
unicycle with machine guns it is Florida
anything's possible could be a gun a
hang glider and [ __ ] hang glider on a
tommy gun no so uh they're saying that
he foreshadow his death so I'm gonna
play a clip from when he was like
screaming so he's Tupac now hey
worst thing comes to worst I [ __ ] die
a tragic death or some [ __ ] and I'm not
able to see out my dreams I at least
want to know that the kids perceived my
message and were able to make something
of themselves and able to take my
message and use it and turn it into
something positive and to at least have
a good life I at least good for him if
I'm gonna die or ever be a sacrifice I
want to make sure that my life made at
least 5 million kids happy or they found
some sort of answers or resolved in my
life regardless of the negative around
my name regardless well he didn't really
for boat his death that's just him
talking that's not a well he was
obviously scared he was gonna die
did anyone start the count to see how
many kids are positively affected yeah 5
million
he made 5 million kids happy was doing
some charity work yeah but then I did
see a bunch of
current celebs that were saying how
inspired they were by my Kanye the game
like a lot of people are like I actually
really liked his music and this like
this news hurts me or whatever
yeah it's messed up man yeah there's a
ton of celebrities that were just well
even his ex-girlfriend who he
domestically abused yeah she was still
like I lost someone close to me and
broken a lot of people were messaging
her being like are you like yeah are you
celebrating are you happy and she's like
no I'm broken yeah she actually went to
the vigil that they had and they kicked
her out like fans kicked her out from
the vigil and then they actually grabbed
the stuff that she brought for him and
burned it that's terrible it's like
sobbing why I thought you wanted his
fans to do positive things because of
because she wouldn't when she was
accusing him then it like made a riff in
the fan the fan base started hating on
her like he actually went to jail for it
well yeah if he beat the [ __ ] out of her
that he should have know for sure but if
you're a hardcore fan you're like you
probably faked it right it's by what the
fans are saying yes it's so dumb another
thing that made headlines about this is
that there was a memorial here in
Hollywood and cops started shooting
rubber bullets at the fans because they
just got out of control turn into a riot
so I show you guys this was on Melrose
right yeah so the fans are listening to
him at all the fans aren't listening to
him he wants to have a 5 million a
positive influence everyone's going
crazy yeah does Melrose Bulevar
look how much of an influence he had
did one of those she service [ __ ]
women the salad stuff here
that looks like a movie Wow I know
exactly where that is just start firing
people were throwing rocks at the cops
damn dude well that's what I'm saying
like you know that's just him talking
you know people are like see how
positive he was or whatever I don't know
the kid or anything else like that he
was not like if you listen to his music
well that's what I'm hearing they're
using like small anecdotal clips to
represent who his character is right but
then a lot of people do that they just
[ __ ] blab on Instagram made Eustatius
a young man trying to be a positive
light for the future doesn't matter what
you say it's about how you behave in act
and that's true it's your behavior that
people remember the most yeah versus
what you say and so like there's just
like there's just like split because
like number one I think like people are
a little bit harsh on one side because
there's like I'm glad he died but yo the
kid was 20 when I was 20 I wasn't a
great kid either yeah you know and so
like the the experience that I had after
the age of 20s where I grew the most it
sucks that he had to die because you
know who knows in his 30s he could have
like went the way totally way different
direction yeah and then when people say
that you know on the other side they're
like well you know aside from the fact
that I just mentioned like that's their
thing and the other people are saying
like well he you know well he was doing
better things it doesn't erase
everything else that he did and it's not
a reflection of who he is as a person
like people like for example I'll use
like my favorite example is Tupac to
puck was he was lyrical he was a poet he
was highly intelligent doesn't change
the fact you know he was a gangster yeah
I mean he was like a cop killer doesn't
change any of that stuff you know what I
mean so you can't like admonish what
somebody does after the fact he dies
because you want to glorify him in a
good way doesn't change what he did it
you're being too fair right now David
you got two sides in this society in
this day and age everything is black and
white there are no Gray's there is no
middle ground if you're on one side
you're not on the other you're an enemy
of the other people are so we probably
heard his music I just didn't know his
name was mr. tentacles and
that isn't our generation was to pop
trout thing y'all could just feel
however the [ __ ] you want to feel bad
ain't it the cod that's how old I am at
I don't know [ __ ] yeah unless I love the
beats it's on the beach anymore the beat
the beat I don't know what they're
saying it was like I love the beach too
that was random but I liked it
[Music]